The new year (Yancuiic xihuitl / η Πρωτοχρονιά
/ la jaro nova / el año nuevo / le nouvel an /
ka makahiki hou / s’annu nou e fintzas
“cabuannu”).
2014 was a year of getting to know these guys
and you guys a bit better - I’m not shy
about it, you really are the best bits of
this channel.
It was a year for experiments - we eavesdropped
on linguistic tics of travel destinations,
we pondered whimsical questions (that’s
not pondering, Mr F, give us a good pondering…
there it is!), ahem, we even wandered off
into animvloggy creativeness. Ok, I retract
“we” from that last one - I dragged you,
some of you maybe against your will.
We skipped from idea to idea with little care
for what internets was yearning to learn about
language. Many questions went unanswered.
Many fears surfaced because OMG WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE LESSONS!?!
Now we end up, poetically, right where we
started: pondering language. That’s a good
pondering.
December cleared up my backlog and ended us
in a den of animal communication! And now,
as promised, I’m face to face with decipherment.
I’m even taking a step back to think about
writing systems in general. So, alongside
an unwieldily awesomely growing list of languagey
suggestions from you, I sense the graphological
thread unraveling throughout 2015. So keep
on keeping me in check. After all, we’ve
both seen you’re super good at that.
Subscribe for a happy new year and happy language!